Hello friends and members of the Son TV
family. My name is C.A. Murray and
you're watching I'd like to know, our
Bible question and answer program. To my
right Pastor Stephen Bohr, the president
and founder of this ministry. To my left
Pastor David Salazar, who is the general
manager of our Latino network. And we
are so happy and blessed that you are
here with us to hear and answer these
Bible-based questions. Should you have a
question, we encourage you to write us
at tv@son.tv.org. That's
tv@son.tv.org.
We
take the privilege of combining some
questions. Every now and again we get
questions
we get multiple questions on the same
issue. So what we will do is address the
issue and not the particular question so
that your question is answered as we
look at the overall issue. So we
encourage you to write. Others may have
the same burden as you, so we will
always address the issue if not every
individual question. So we thank you for
that. Hope that's plain and
you understand it because we do want you
to write. You have a burden, we want to
address that burden and answer your
question as the Bible gives us knowledge
and gives us light. Pastor Salazar,
would you please ask God's blessing on
this particular program and then we will
launch out. Certainly.
Heavenly Father, we thank you Lord for
allowing us once again to come before
your throne of grace and we know that
you want to grant us
the best gift which is the spirit, the
Holy Spirit, so that we may receive the
instruction, the guidance, the
understanding of your scriptures. And we
pray that you will allow us to be able
to answer today the questions through
your word and through
a word and expression that will bring
the
the expression and the people closer to
you to understand you better, to
understand your word and to uplift your
name. We thank you for your grace. We
pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.
>> Amen. Our first question comes from from
Sabrina from the United Kingdom and
we're going to kind of move to this
quickly because we were debating we may
have looked at this question before even
if in in a different language in Spanish
and not English. I do not remember
answering it before so we want to just
look at the question and maybe give you
a few biblical points to redress your
particular question. Sabrina, what is
your position on deliverance ministry?
Is there a rightful place for this
within the church? Deliverance ministry.
Pastor Bohr, we'll start with you.
Well,
the the question is somewhat ambiguous
because it does not define what
deliverance ministries are.
>> Mhm.
Based on my experience, deliverance
ministries is where you directly
confront demons that you suspect that
people have.
And in many cases you talk to the demons
and the demons talk back to you. Mhm.
I'm not sure that that is the gist of
the question,
but
maybe we can have C.A. make some remarks
about deliverance itself.
>> Right. And then we can briefly address
[clears throat] the other. Okay.
What occurred to me is that when we give
our hearts to the Lord,
we are delivered from sin.
So then all real ministry is is
deliverance ministry.
>> Mhm. You are
you are confronted by the presence of
sin. You are confronted by the power of
sin.
>> Mhm. When we give our hearts to the
Lord, Romans 6 tells me that sin does
not have dominion over you anymore.
So that's the power of sin that is
broken. The power of sin is broken. It
doesn't have dominion. It cannot
determine who you are in Christ. It
cannot determine where you are going.
The power of sin is broken. The second
of course is the presence of sin and
a couple of texts, Romans 6:14-16,
2 Corinthians 5:17 tells us that once we
are in Christ and saved, we will be
delivered from the the power of sin and
the presence of sin. Former things are
passed away. The old has become new. So
that the the power of sin, the presence
of sin is broken. We no longer are
slaves to sin. We are released from the
presence of sin,
the power of sin rather. And then once
Christ comes again, we are taken out of
the presence of sin. Sin will no longer
exist in the universe. The former things
are passed away. So that's in its
broadest sense, painting with a very
broad brush. The presence of sin is
broken. The power of sin is broken. Sin
no longer has dominion over us.
And you know Pastor, this is somewhat
what our church believes. We believe in
deliverance as a sanctification
process, as a process of sanctification
where I deliver from the enemy, from the
stronghold of sin in our lives. We're
not
per se
delivered in one moment of a demonic
force and then we're free already or
free forever. It's it's a process of
communion with God, of our relationship
with the Lord that gives you and grants
you that power to overcome and to resist
the temptation, to resist the enemy, to
have
basically the the enemy
flee from you as the Bible speaks of.
You know, resist the devil and he will
flee from you. It's that experience that
you're connected with Christ, you are in
that
experience in deliverance throughout
[clears throat] your life, in every
moment in your life as you're connected
with Christ. The deliverance ministry
that most and this is where I kind of
conquer with Pastor Bohr in the sense
that in my experience when people speak
of delivering ministry or ministry of
deliverance, they usually bring the idea
that a lot of the evangelical and
charismatic churches have where they
have
they attack the demon, they call out the
demon at moment and it's more of a it
doesn't matter whether person believe or
not, you have the power to cast a demon
for that individual. And and
it's even though it's a practice that
often times seems to
have its
effect
apparently, it is more of a
it is not really in in a harmony with
how the scripture presents how you
receive really deliverance from the
enemy. And that means is you have the
desire to walk with Christ, to as a
person you desire to be free from the
demonic
stronghold in your life and through the
prayer, through communion, through the
anointing of elders and pastors, you are
able to receive that freedom and you
continue in that walk with Christ as you
go through your life. That is what the
church in a whole presents
which is a little different from the
specific aspect of our deliverance
ministry that other denominations have
and again
are contrary to what
our church and our biblical
understanding points
to.
Um
you know, the Bible mentions
a case in Acts chapter 19 Mhm. where
certain individuals were casting out
demons
in the name [clears throat] of Christ.
>> Yes.
If you're going to be involved in
casting out demons, you better make sure
that your life is is in order with the
Lord.
>> Amen. Because it's a risky business.
It says in Acts chapter 19
verse 11, now God worked unusual
miracles by the hands of Paul.
So that even handkerchiefs and aprons
were brought from his body to the sick
and the diseases left them
and the evil spirits went out of them.
It says then some of the itinerant Jews
Jewish exorcists
took it upon themselves, that's
important,
>> Mhm. to call the name of the Lord Jesus
over those who had evil spirits saying,
we exercise you by Jesus whom Paul
preaches.
So they were actually They're telling on
themselves.
>> claiming to cast out demons in the name
of Jesus.
Okay?
>> [laughter]
>> And so it says in verse 14, also there
were seven sons of Sceva, a Jewish chief
priest who did the so.
And the evil spirit answered and said,
Jesus I know
>> Mhm. and Paul I know,
but who are you?
Obviously this person was not in a good
relationship with the Lord.
>> No. Then the man in whom the evil spirit
was leaped on them,
overpowered them and prevailed against
them so they fled out of that house
naked and wounded.
>> That's one thing. Now,
there's a case in Mark
where actually two cases in Mark where
Jesus actually
had a conversation with the demon.
Mark chapter 1 verse 21 says, then they
went into Capernaum and immediately on
the Sabbath he entered the synagogue and
taught.
And they were astounded at his teaching
for he taught them as one having
authority and not as the scribes.
Now there was a man in their synagogue
with an unclean spirit and he cried out
saying, let us alone.
What have we to do with you, Jesus of
Nazareth? Did you come to destroy us? I
know who you are, the holy one of God."
And then Jesus says, "Be quiet."
And he cast him out.
And then of course you have the
conversation with
the demons that were cast out of the
swine.
With in Gadara.
>> Um
And the Apostle Paul mentions exorcism
as one of the gifts of the Spirit.
The the gift of casting out demons.
Um however, there are some individuals
in the deliverance ministry that find a
demon behind every stone. Mhm. Uh
they're actually looking for conflicts
[clears throat]
with the demon. Yeah. Um and so those
individuals are not following the
biblical pattern where you might have a
case where a person is demon-possessed,
but
uh you should make sure your life is in
order with the Lord.
And uh you should not look for
uh cases where you want to cast out
demons.
Certain circumstances that will be
necessary. These
seven sons of Sceva
almost appear the Bible presents them as
sort of
circuit-riding demon chaser kind of
thing, you know? The
The text doesn't say that they had a
particularly close relationship with
Jesus. They're they're casting out Jesus
in the name of Jesus and somebody that
Paul knows. And say, "We know him. We're
not we're
It's not a personal relationship. Um it
was almost like a an occupation of a
visit a business kind of a thing. Um
and and the devil told them, "I I know"
and the word know there means has
respect for.
Paul, Jesus of course, but I don't know
you guys, you know?" Mhm. "Who do you
think you are to to try to think you can
order me around? Yeah. You have no
power.
>> Yeah. Uh and so he put them in in their
places. This this idea of confronting
demons is very serious business.
>> Yes.
>> Um uh and unless you are prayed up with
prayed up with Christ and unless you
have an assignment from Christ to do
that kind of thing, that's not something
you want to jump into
uh confronting confronting the devil.
The Bible says if I surrender with to
Jesus,
God gives me
the spirit, the ability to resist the
devil. Yeah. But
me coming to you and say, "Pastor Bohr,
I'm going to knock the devil out of
you." You know, that's not that's
[laughter] not biblical, man.
>> Yeah, that's my ministry.
Yeah, that's that's why I walk on the
earth to just go around and cast the
devil out of folk. I'm I'm very very
afraid of that thing. So, does it have a
place?
Deliverance ministry has a place, but
you have to be very very careful when
you tread on some of these areas that
God has not specifically called us to.
>> And you know the text that I read from
Acts chapter 19 Yeah. it confirms what
you just said. It says in verse 13 of
chapter 19, "Then some of the itinerant
Jewish exorcists" so their profession
was exorcism according to this.
>> Um it continues saying
um
once again, verse 13. "Then some of the
itinerant Jewish exorcists took it upon
took it upon themselves
>> Upon themselves.
>> Mhm. to call the name of the Lord Jesus
over those who had evil spirits." In
other words, it's not this one occasion.
They're making a professional out of it.
>> that's what they're doing, yeah.
>> Um and I believe that sometimes you have
to confront devils.
But you don't see a devil uh or a demon
behind every stone, so to speak.
And you don't look
for the opportunity of casting out
demons.
>> Yes, yes.
>> The time will come when you will have to
do it, but you don't search for it.
Exactly. Yeah.
By Jesus whom Paul preaches. Not by
Jesus who we know. Not by the power of
Jesus in our lives. This is kind of
third-hand exorcism. It's not even the
real deal. So, we've dealt with that and
Sabrina, thank you for your question. We
pray that we've we've entertained it and
dealt with it
thoroughly. And thank you for sending.
Um
The name of this next person is Toolit.
T O O L I T and they're writing to us
from Uganda. A place that I've visited
and preached in a few times.
So, thank you Toolit for your question.
Here's the question.
"Praise the living God. Hope all is
well." We we like that when they kind of
give that little blessing.
"What does buying and selling mean in
Revelation 13?
Could it be literal or spiritual? And
also I'd like to understand what the
moon and the 12 stars are on the head of
the pregnant woman who represents uh
who represents from Revelation still.
So, one is Revelation 12 and the other
is Revelation 13." Um he he brought it
to us 13 first. So, let's go to 13 and
talking about buying and selling. Of
course you've got two beasts in
Revelation 13 as we know well know. Sea
beast in the first chapter
Revelation 13:11 becomes the the land
beast
and that's where we deal with the the
buying and selling. So, let me let me go
over to Revelation.
And um
Do you have Pastor Bohr the text
particularly that he is referencing?
Uh let me get there.
Yeah, it's uh Revelation 13 verse 16 I
think it might be 15 or 16. Yeah.
Okay.
It says there, "He causes all both small
and great, rich and poor, free and slave
to receive a mark on the right hand or
on their foreheads." Verse 17, "And that
no one may buy or sell except one who
has the mark or the name of the beast or
the number of his name."
Mhm.
>> So, those are the two verses
16 and 17 that speak of
those who will not be able to buy or
sell unless they have the mark of the
beast of the beast on their right hand
or in their forehead. Okay. The mark of
the beast of course is against a country
controverted by the the seal of God.
Seal of God, mark of the beast. Um this
comes after Revelation 13:11. So, it's
in the time of the second beast, the
land beast. Um
which is the second beast of Revelation
chapter 13.
The question that I think he wants to
know is is it literal or spiritual
buying or selling?
There there is a text in the book of
Proverbs
that might help us with this. And uh
before I read that verse
um I might uh
give this explanation.
The final battle is over the truth.
Whether you receive the seal of God,
which is the observance of the Sabbath,
or you receive the mark of the beast,
which is knowingly keeping Sunday when
you know that it's the Sabbath. That's
the day of rest.
In other words, what you're doing is
you're selling the truth.
Right? Yes.
>> Mhm. So, you can So, you can sell the
truth
and be under a death decree.
Or you can buy the truth
and you can buy the truth rather and be
under a death decree or you can sell the
truth and be spared the death decree.
>> Yes. Now, this verse is very interesting
in that context. It says
ver Proverbs 23 verse 23, "Buy the truth
and sell it not. And do not sell it.
>> Amen.
Also wisdom and instruction and
understanding." So,
uh is this literal not being able to buy
or sell? Um I believe that it is literal
that you're not going to be able to buy
or sell,
but why are you not able to buy or sell?
Because because you embraced the truth.
>> Precisely. Why will you be able to buy
or sell? Because you sold the truth.
>> Right. So, it's not either or. It is
really both and.
>> Indeed. Indeed. Well said. Well said. Um
And of course as we said before, this is
under the the auspices of the second
beast, the land beast, which we know is
the United States in prophecy. Mhm. So,
this is going to take place during that
time in which we now live. Now, it's
important that the the the mark of the
beast
or the the seal of God do not come until
it's enforced. So, it's not it's not
right now. It's it's it's in the future,
but it is coming and you know, what
decisions we make now will predetermine
the kind of decisions we will make then
when we're forced to make a decision one
way or the other.
What we drew what we do with the truth
is the determining point. Yes.
And I I think that's what Proverbs is
trying to emphasize.
>> I agree.
>> So, I don't think that it's only you
know, not being able to buy or sell. Why
are you not going to be able to buy or
sell? Well, because you embraced the
truth.
>> Did you embrace the truth? Why will you
be able to buy or sell? Well, because
you've you've sold the truth. Yeah. Uh
so, I think that this verse helps us.
And And and now and now just to say and
answering his question, could it be
literal or spiritual?
It's going to be
uh literal
but also in a sense spiritual as well.
So, but you know, it is both in this
particular
scenario. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
we and we dealt with this a couple of
programs back.
If you're faithful in the little things
now,
um you'll be faithful in the big things
then. If you're making little making
making little compromises on the
Sabbath, on honesty, on integrity, now,
it'll be much easier for you to just
cave in when your life is on the line.
>> Mhm. You know, but if you are accustomed
to and have accustomed yourself to
standing for the Lord in little things,
then when the big thing is come, you
will be prepared to stand for the Lord.
And the truth is this test is coming to
us all who are alive during that time.
No one is going to escape. You've got to
make a decision for or against the Lord.
We get all hung up on Armageddon and war
and this and that and the other. Really,
uh your your it's it's the battle is
between good and evil. The contest is
good and evil. If you are accustomed to
caving in to evil now, then you will
cave in on that day.
>> Mhm. So, what you do now, what you do
every day of your life, kind of
predetermines what's going to happen
when the big test comes. That's a good
question. Uh and we thank him for it.
Now, we we've got the other part the 12
the woman with the 12 stars. Let me go
to Revelation 12 uh 1 and read that. Uh
and provide some broad-based commentary
on the answer. Now, a great sign
appeared in heaven, a woman clothed with
the sun, and the moon under her feet,
and on her head a garland of 12 stars.
Then being with child, she cried out in
labor and in pain to give birth. Now,
whenever you're dealing with a woman in
Revelation, what are we dealing with?
It is the the church.
>> Church.
>> Okay. So, that's that's a a begin to
begin unraveling uh this. And a a
pregnant woman, well, the only real
entity that the church birth is Christ.
>> is Christ.
>> Mhm.
>> So, you you you begin to set up the
bricks in your wall even by just looking
at what the Bible has told you. So, it
it's not as difficult a text as you may
think. Um [snorts]
she's got 12 stars and the moon under
her feet. So, what is that what is that
talking about?
Okay, uh basically this woman of
Revelation 12 represents the Old and New
Testament Church.
>> Thank you. We know that she represents
the Old Testament Church because she
exists before the child is born.
>> Mhm.
>> [laughter]
>> So, that would be the Old Testament
Church. After the child is born, then
she represents the New Testament Church.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> I see the beings and all those things.
Right. Now, with that in mind, why the
number 12?
Well, because the founders of the Old
Testament Church were 12.
>> The 12. The 12 patriarchs.
And the founders of the New Testament
Church were also 12, the 12 apostles.
So, the number 12 represents the church
in the Old Testament and the church
>> The New Testament.
>> in the New Testament. In other words,
God's church in all periods of history.
>> you. All age. Now, um why the sun? The
sun represents the fulfillment of the
Old Testament. The moon represents the
shadows and the reflections
that pointed to the time when the woman
would be clothed with the sun. In other
words, um the Old Testament gives
testimony to Christ. Mhm.
>> In other words, the Old Testament is
like the moon whose light gives witness
to the light of the sun. In other words,
the moon pointed to the fulfillment
of everything that is in the Old
Testament to the greater light in the
times of Christ. Uh Ellen White had an
interesting statement where she wrote,
"As in the Old Testament, the 12
patriarchs
stood as representatives of Israel,
so the 12 apostles stand as
representatives of the gospel church."
>> Amen.
>> That's Acts of the Apostles, page 16.
And then in another statement, Acts of
the Apostles, page 18, she wrote, "It
was at the ordination of the 12 that the
first step was taken in the organization
of the church that after Christ's
departure was to carry on his work on
the earth." Amen.
>> So, the number 12 represents the 12
patriarchs, the 12 apostles that form
the foundation of the church. Of course,
Jesus Christ being the chief
cornerstone. Amen. She was clothed with
the sun. So, she's under the auspices of
Christ. When you're looking at something
that seems a bit foreign,
take those elements that you know what
the Bible explains
>> Yes. and then apply them and then it's
not quite so so weighty a a thing to to
give your exegesis up. Amen.
>> Thank you so much, Pastor Bohr, Pastor
Salazar. Good question, very good
answers. Uh not quite as tough as it
seem as it seems when you use basic
biblical principles Amen.
>> to answer basic biblical questions. We
hope this program has been a blessing to
to you. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.